Yunker would do account and that we are
the future we're going to be adults is
how we gonna sort of is fire our
generations make a change so I think
today is really about them trying to put
faith back into young people it's hard
to stand up be counted and asked the
leaders very much in the
first-past-the-post electoral system
there are many marginal seats where your
party is unlikely to win and I'd be
interested to know in those seeds and
which parties do you advise your
supporters to vote for what I would urge
everyone to do obviously I'd like you to
vote green but what I would like you to
do is vote for the person part of your
policies in your constituency who best
represents your views those policies
that really feel like that's the person
who I'd like to represent me if people
did that people went out and voted vote
for what they believe in whatever that
is we could actually have a peaceful
political revolution one of the things I
say is you I'd like you to vote green
I'd like you to vote for someone you
believe in but if there's no one on the
ballot paper who you think you know
represent your views still go to the
polling station and if you want to write
a rude word on the ballot paper because
if you don't vote if you just don't turn
up you don't register your countered
with the I'm happy enough with how
things are part of group and I don't
think most people actually are to what
extent do you think that unpaid
internships are justifiable I think
unpaid internships are absolutely
unjustifiable and the Green Party calls
for them to be banned what we've
actually seen is a situation where what
used to be first jobs the job you'd
expect to go into and get paid you're a
reasonable salary for after you left
university or after you left school or
college let's now become an unpaid
internship some people actually do end
up doing unpaid internships because it's
a way to get their foot through the door
is a way to get experience to wait to
you know hopefully get a job which
usually isn't a guarantee so I think
maybe what we should be looking at is
the job market much widely for young
people who are graduating and unable to
find jobs or then forced to get into
internships yeah yes I think that's an
important point I would in no way blame
anyone who takes one of these because
she doing what you have to do I was
surprised actually at how much
resistance within the room there was to
banning unpaid internships then I was
sort of expecting oh here we go here's
the first applause line but actually a
lot of people in that room seemed quite
supportive of the idea and they should
be made to work for free for six months
I thought was a good answer I really did
and I was nice to see actually cuz I
don't think we see enough of her the
only thing is and I like her policy the
fact that we should ban them but the
only thing I don't know how realistic
that is sir measures would you put in
place to help solve the housing crisis
our generation are facing with more and
more young people moving back home and
even when there is the introduction of
the housing schemes okay well this I
think is that is the one issue that
people come to me most often about we
have to get away from the idea of
housing as a financial asset and get
back to them being homes so one of the
key so that is build much more council
housing yep genuine the affordable
housing not what's so called affordable
housing in London which is 85 eighty
percent of market rents but what we want
to do also is put a cap on private rents
I wanted to know what moves you are
inspires you as a person today I think
I'm going to go back to the to the very
start of my politics which is I became a
feminist at age five I didn't actually
know the word then but at age five I was
told because you're a girl you're not
allowed to have a bicycle and at that
point I thought that's not fair or
reasonable why should because I'm a girl
stop me doing that and that sense of
fairness and the sense that so many
people are stopped from realizing their
potential doing what they want to do
because of unfair rules society putting
restrictions on them you know that to me
is what kind of drives me in the sense
of I want everyone to have a chance for
a decent quality of life I think she
needs to work on being able to show that
this is something that really drives her
we saw some of that when she started
talking about her only story
she said that she was a feminist age
five because she was told girls couldn't
have bicycles I thought there was a
lovely story personal stories that that
work really well in politics but you
need to be able to get passionate about
policies as well
the labour leader ed miliband talking to
run this as Prime Minister how would you
engage with the vast majority of
peaceful patriotic British Muslims to
tackle the extremist ideology of Isis
and will you start to heat the advice of
British Muslims that our foreign policy
is a fact in the radicalization of young
people and will you reconsider Britain's
international state Britain's
international stage with the Muslim
world woman mubeen listings are really
it's a really important question let me
say a couple of things first of all
about what we should be doing here at
home and secondly what we should be
doing internationally terms what we
should be doing here at home I think
what's what we know about radicalization
of young people is the best thing we can
do is prevent it happening not deal with
it after it happens and what I want to
see a lot more of is engaging with young
Muslims community groups and others
there's a program called prevent now
that's at the moment led by the police I
think it should be actually much more
about community groups and saying how do
we prevent radicalization which we all
share but the second thing I'd say to
you is this look on foreign policy I
have changed our position well I think
the war in Iraq was a mistake and I've
said that right so I would you would you
agree that foreign policy is a factor in
the radicalization yes or no I think it
is being used I think it is being used
to say to people that somehow they
should kind of take a different view and
take an extremist view but I've got to
say to you think about ISIL right ISIL
is killing Muslims all over the world
they are not indiscriminate about who
they kill I was wondering recently
there's been a lot of media coverage on
right-wing parties and their popularity
are you worried by this tool which
parties are you talking about things
like you keep and people like that you
know I'm incredibly proud of the fact
that we're an open tolerant country I'm
the son of immigrants my parents came
here as refugees from the Nazis and I
think that is one of the great things
about Britain that we are open and
tolerant that the view i take about this
is we got it kind of champion our
openness and I diversity but we've got
to make it work let me give you one
specific example where I think it
doesn't work at the moment you get a
situation where people are being brought
here pay less than the minimum
age or 15 people being put in their
house now that exploits migrant workers
but it also undercuts wages so you see I
think most of the time people's concerns
aren't based on prejudice they're based
on reality when people see that
happening they still hang on it that's
not fair how will you ensure tax
incurred in the UK gets paid in the UK
and goes to those who need it most well
this is a really important question that
Kevin asks and there's nothing I think
that annoys people more than tax
avoidance by big companies now I think a
couple of things first of all we've got
to act internationally because that's
the best way of clamping down on this
but also we've got to be willing to act
on our own there are other countries
like Denmark and others who do a much
better job of actually clamping down on
tax avoidance by big firms now this is
in the news at the moment because
yesterday the chairman of booths start
telling people how to vote in the UK
general election well it turns out that
the chairman of boots lives in Monaco
and is actually avoiding his taxes now
you know I just got to say to you I
don't think people in Britain are going
to take kindly to being lectured by
somebody who's avoiding his taxes on how
they should be voting at the UK general
election and you've now got this unholy
alliance between the Conservative Party
and people like him who are actually
saying that the country can't change I
think we can change the country and I
think part of my job is say we're going
to stand up to these powerful forces who
aren't paying their taxes we're avoiding
their taxes because frankly they have a
responsibility you know we talk a lot
about responsibility in our society I
think responsibility goes from top to
bottom in our country one of the reasons
politicians like him talk about tax
avoidance is because of groups like UK
Uncut where young people took to the
streets and occupied businesses and
shops whose owners were avoiding tax
that is forced people like Ed Miliband
rightly to engage with the issue parties
present their manifestos and I don't
think at any point that they do it in a
way that suitable for young people yes
you ever thought about creating huge
friendly manifesto so we can actually
start to understand what's going on
really important question we've got
we're going to have a young people's
manifesto now I launched that process a
couple of weeks ago you should go to the
Labour website to look at how you can
get engaged with that I think it's
incredibly important that we have a
young manifester that does reflect the
wishes of
people let me one other point G
Elizabeth and then come back we're going
to give the vote to 16 and 17 year olds
now one of some people likes being favor
of that some people might be against it
why do I think it's import their one and
a half million 16 and 17 year old take
the EMA for example it was abolished in
one sentence of a budget speech without
and I think it George Osborne wouldn't
have done that if actually he thought 16
and 17 year old convo it's also about
trust in young people and I think it's
great when they're talking about the
youth manifesto and getting out because
to get people into politics I think um
often it's a very gradual thing and
sometimes you're when you're especially
if you're voting for the first time and
you start looking into okay Who am I
going to vote for if you if you don't
know much about the political system
sometimes you do want something laid out
for you to get you involved you don't
want to go oh what does this guy like
and then see a million and one
contradicting points and blame being
pushed on other people who you don't
even necessarily understand what
everyone does and that can lead you to
not voting because I think you can go
all you know this isn't for me this is
all too complicated just quickly wanted
to say I probably won't have gone to
university without EMA so I think that
if you piña can reaffirm bringing EMA
back that would just basically be great
we need to look at all of these things
Barbara I will say one thing to you
though I can't at the moment promise to
bring it back and I'll tell you why
because we've got to make the sums an up
and we've got to get the deficit down
and you know there is one issue here
which I do want to go to about politics
and why people are so cynical about
politics lots of politicians come along
in opposition and basically say I'm
going to make a promise to you on a
program like this and then I'll really
hope you don't catch up with me in
government and if I do if you do I'll
kind of run around the corner and hope I
can avoid you I don't think we can do
that so look we're going to look at all
of these issues but we'll make promises
we know we can keep just to move on to a
question about yourself yeah and outside
of politics what experience do you have
what life experience do you have to
associate and indicate that you should
be the one to represent the people of
Britain well I've done a number of
things which I think I hope are relevant
to this so i was obviously an economic
advisor in the Treasury and i think
that's important i think that's
important because you know the economy
and how we change our economy is at the
heart of the country I've taught I
taught at Harvard University and
probably all agree on which from that is
when he was asked how he can relate to
real people and or what any of the need
yet he immediately went for finance and
Harvard and it's immediately people
going oh no no no no that answer where
he said he was an advanced advisor at
the Treasury and then he worked at
Harvard I mean path should be played
over and over again as an example of why
young people aren't exactly engaging
with that middle back
now to turn over the leader of the
Liberal Democrats and Deputy Minister
Nick Clegg Thank You mr. clay why should
we feel like we can trust you obviously
we understand it was part of a coalition
and that combinations have to be made
but we've seen now that actually as we
all knew originally it's not going to
work out the high-end tuition fees it's
not going to get repaid what's your
stance are you are you sorry for the
fact that you weren't able to reduce it
to zip reduce to zero the tuition fee so
like I've them I've I'm not on the last
party or question i've i've apologized
musically no less no kind of us actually
very important points your sister yeah i
see your sisters who it's really
important to know just forget you know
politics and and you know and I'll come
to that in a minute of course oh god
I've always taken this on the chin I'll
do it again I just for your sister and
for people wanting to go to university
please don't what you said somehow
suggests that she is paying three times
she's not which is the reason of course
why despite all the predictions at the
time more youngsters are now going to
university never before more youngsters
from disadvantaged backgrounds are going
to university than ever before more
youngsters from black minority ethnic
backgrounds are going to university than
ever before why because unlike the fee
system you had under the previous Labour
government your sister doesn't have to
pay anything upfront and she doesn't
have to pay anything back only until she
can afford to do so I think the question
was really good from the out from you
know Luke in the audience I think that
he started quite well he's quite relaxed
he had like the Greeks to resist I'll
note I look but then when it got to
tuition fees he could see to tell he was
really quite rattled it was a detailed
and straight response was it oh very
aggressive and sometimes like i felt
quite attacked him when i was doing it I
mean obviously I understood that there
is no way to make everyone happy with
something like this you know we can't
have an answer that fits everyone but it
did feel kind of like I was being
belittled while I was being talking
about it like I should have seen that
actually that I'm not paying as much but
the fact is I'm still paying three times
the amount of money albeit is going to
be over a longer period
time of course I've apologized to the
fact that that particular policy of my
parties we couldn't implement I
sometimes wish I only point this out i
sometimes wish i could hear an apology
from david camera for not implementing
his policy that he promised he would on
immigration or ed miliband for crashing
the economy in the first place but there
you go that's the way these things are
what I do think I'm entitled to say is
if you look at the details of the system
we put in place it was the next best
thing it is in effect like it is in
effect like a graduate taxi only pay
when you can and you need pay what you
can afford to my saying thank you Luke
we have to we have to move on just
looking quick responses to that and she
obviously it's burning issue carissa
just because it gives a couple sentences
I mean but that being said as you said
that over the three years we're
basically paying we have basically have
to pay three times more than we will
when your Universal no but the thing is
it why should I be paying that much
amount for money when I may even secure
the graduate job after that's okay we'll
just take a couple more attempt to climb
in it but can I just explain okay so if
you don't get a great in other words if
you don't get a job which which pays
well then you don't pay anything at all
yeah but but here's that here's here's
the thing okay forget the qualifications
of coalition to get me to get the
Liberal Democrats if you had carried on
with the system before right the fee
system which was introduced by labor in
2003 it's really important you
understand this when you left University
you would have to start paying back the
moment you started earning 15,000 pounds
it's not a very high income right under
the new system you don't have to pay
when you when you're only 15 or 16 or 17
or 18 or 19 or 20 or twitter you only
start paying when you start paying back
when you start earning 21,000 pounds or
more so I have to I you know in the same
way that you of course should be blunt
with me I have to be blunt with you this
is the only question where the audience
Caleb round of applause the questioner
people were clearly quite angry and what
I find interesting is that Clegg still
speaks as if I did it's 2010 as if he's
never been in power as if he's a fresh
face when in actual fact that in the
past government he seems to me he seems
shadow cheerleader until you ever
thought the overwhelming pressure
because of party politics and and trying
to you know stay with what your party
wants we've got your coalition as well
do you feel like you're compromising
yourself though so sure I can i
just--can i to really important
pointless um i would love to be Prime
Minister of course i would i'd love to
input i'd love to not have these
questions from Luke wasn't it of course
I wouldn't have a keep it being of
course I'd like so yeah I could do
exactly what I wanted my whole manifest
rental it's a democracy I didn't win the
election did you feel sorry for him that
he's that he's had this for years he's
had a tough time and now he's got a
standard error and defend a record that
he might not necessarily be that proud
of no I don't feel sorry for him at all
because that's his job and that's what
he he obviously wants to to do he wants
to be successful he wants to be a leader
so that you have to do you have to lower
the punches on that one and now it's
returned as the leader of the
conservative and the current Prime
Minister David Cameron Prime Minister
thank you very much making hits yes how
are people in zero hour contracts
expected to pay for their food rent
travel and then expected to pay plan for
their financial futures well what we
want Michael is to make sure we've got
decent jobs for everybody and in this
economy we have seen more people get
work about 1.75 million more people
getting work since I became prime
minister but there is no doubt that
you're right there are some zero-hours
contracts where people are abused and so
we've said the 0 as contracts where
companies can effectively forbid you
from working for anybody else we've said
that is wrong and we've legislated to
stop that you say that um it's good for
people to go to university about the
same time there are graduates and
undergraduates who have no jobs that are
high employment would you say to this
well what I think is what we should do
as a country is make available
apprenticeships and university places so
that everyone who feels they can benefit
from going to university can go he
really looked somewhere between
uncomfortable and almost dismissive he
didn't
look as if he wanted to be there I do
think he warmed up David Cameron does a
lot of these sessions where he goes into
work places and stands in front of a JCB
and talks to people on the road but I
think seeing a load of sort of young
people who just don't really care about
what their boss thinks just giving in
both barrels it's quite different from
the average political interview and I
think the best thing was watching some
of the reactions on the questioners
faces when they didn't think what he
gave was up to scratch but kind of
showed it without really really holding
back and I would advise when it comes to
my own children first in a primary
school I'd advise them as you go through
school think about either doing an
apprenticeship or think about going to
university rather than leaving school at
sixteen or eighteen he struggles when he
tries to sort of pretend to be a man of
the people so he was asked about
apprenticeships and started talking
about his children and saying that he
might advise his children when they
leave school to do an apprenticeship and
I kind of develop I just winced at that
quite at Britain fly the Saudi flag at
half-mast if the country has such an
appalling human rights record the reason
for doing that was that there's a
long-standing relationship between the
kingdom of saudi arabia and our united
kingdom here a relationship between our
monarchs relationship between the
government's we don't agree with lots of
things that the Saudis do we don't agree
with the way they treat people for
instance criminals when we make very
clear those differences but when the
King died as a mark of respect we
thought it was right to show that
respect that isn't that disrespectful to
the people who the Saudi King has
sentenced two thousand lashes and you
mentioned that there's a relief
the question there was absolutely
fantastic when he said it's a case of
respect and she said what about the
respect for all the people who've been
tortured by this regime that a tray of
food are we the bloggers who is waiting
to be flogged again and partly sentence
of a thousand lashes the trouble that is
realpolitik there is no answer to that
you cannot as Prime Minister say yes I
think they're quite unpleasant people
but we need them that's not something
say so I did feel for him slightly there
because it there is a very obvious
answer that question it is just that he
cannot to give it by virtue of being
Prime Minister Christopher didn't wire
the Tories going to scrap housing
benefit at 16 to 21 year olds when every
pensioner still gets the winter fuel
allowance well the reason for this is I
think as I've been saying earlier when
young people leave school I think there
should be opportunities to earn by doing
an apprenticeship or getting a job or
opportunities to learn by an
apprenticeship or going to university
but i think the option of leaving school
signing on moving out of home getting a
flat and living on housing benefit i
don't think that is any start to a life
at all so i don't think it should be an
option now of course there are some
people who for whatever reason cannot
live at home and have to be away from
their parents and they we will always
help but the option that some people
have today of leaving school signing on
unemployed getting a flat getting
housing benefit I don't think that is a
good option for young people and I don't
think it should be available I think
that's a very bad approach because
you're using example of a small minority
of people that just sign up for the
second signing on to punish a large
majority of the people who actually do
sign on for so many reasons you know
they have kids so they can't leave a
home because of family issues and
problems as somebody who can actually
leave at home at eighteen who decided to
go back to fe college and then are now
at uni Housing Benefit was the only way
that I could do and I think that you're
making a big mistake by taking that away
from young people well I don't agree
that this is somehow a tiny minority of
people what I'm saying is if you have to
leave home if you can't stay at home
then of course you should make that
benefit available which party leader
will eradicate the farcical Prime
Minister's question time don't we have
enough comedies on TV without having
this rerun over and over again and again
now this is the real a men oh look I I
at five minutes to twelve every
wednesday i can tell you i put my head
in my hands and think why have I got to
do this it's a nightmare but
does it have a purpose I don't know
maybe you all think it hasn't gone I
think there is there are two points to
it I suppose one is that members of
parliament from whatever party they can
ask you any question they like and so
you've got to try and be on top of your
game and on top of everything that's
happening and that has a knock-on
advantage which is it means that as
Prime Minister you've got to know
everything that's going on in your
government and so it does enforce some
accountability of the departments and
the ministers to you and through you to
Parliament so yes it is noisy and crazy
and infuriating and all the rest of it
but there is some some sort of point to
it does that make any sense well that's
asking all this ask risk what do you
think Krispy scrapped it or do it I
think PMQs is horrible I think it's one
of the biggest disengages for voters and
I think it's really petty I think
everybody involved including yourself
and you stand there you stand there and
you can't you're shouting other members
the house it's disgusting and I think
it's horrible I think well I think it
worth I do you think 16 17 year-olds
should be allowed to vote in elections
right what if you think I've said some
unpopular thing so far wait for this I i
I'm afraid I think the you've got to
have one age of majority and I think 18
is in my view I understand the case for
votes for 16 and 17 year old but my view
is 18 is a is a better age it's the age
where so many other things kick in and I
think it'd be better to save that voting
age 4 for 18 online voting I mean I
don't have any objection to it but I
think in a way we're asking the wrong
question you know the reason people
don't vote is not because it's too
complicated to go down to the polling
station the reason people don't vote is
they don't think it makes enough of a
difference and so I think we ought to
focus on trying to make sure our
politics is delivering the things people
want rather than simply just trying to
work out how do we make it easier to
vote I thought it wasn't the strongest
performance I've ever seen as we
discussed before he has I'm a bit of a
sticky wicket this time anyway given
that conservatives don't naturally
appeal to the young he had a difficult
set of policy proposals but by god they
are soon some tough questions than that